ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
DODD.
THE ROUTE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
WHY CASKEY?
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BE ON THE
REAL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE
WILL BE LET IMPROVE THIS MORNING
BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR WIENER.
LET US REMEMBER AGAIN THIS WE'RE
ALWAYS IN GOD'S HOLY PRESENCE.
THE LOTUS WORK THE ONE SAID.
THE THING ABOUT NON VIOLENCE IS
THAT IT SPREAD.
WHEN YOU GET PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN NONVIOLENT ACTION?
PEOPLE ARE LEARNING FROM THAT
ACTION.
GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL GOD OF OUR
PAST AND OF OUR PRESENCE.
HELP US TO CONTINUE TO LEARN
FROM THE NON VIOLENT ACTIONS OF
OUR PREDECESSORS.
WHO STRETCHED BEYOND THEIR
COMFORT ZONES TO REMIND US OF
THE INTERCONNECTEDNESS OF ALL
BEINGS ON THIS FRAGILE PLANET?
MAY OUR LEGISLATORS AND ALL
THOSE IN POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP.
PERSEVERE AND EFFORTS OF
RESPECTFUL DIALOGUE.
SO THAT THE GIFTS AND TALENTS OF
ALL CAN BE SHARED.
IN PEACE AND HARMONY FOR THE
COMMON GOOD.
MAY WE GROW AND AWARENESS OF THE
VIOLENCE OF SOME OF OUR WORDS.
AS WE LEARN TO LISTEN TO THOSE
WHO HAVE LONG BEEN SILENCED.
WE TRUST IN YOUR CONTINUED
INSPIRATION.
BUT AS WE MAY OPERATE FROM
HEARTS OF COMPASSION AND
FAIRNESS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
PLEASE JOIN ME FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG.
YEAH.
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER
GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL [inaudible]
CHAU.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION SENATE
RULE TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE K.
TWO AND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO A
WILL BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO MEET
TODAY FOR SB.
ONE FORTY TWO SENATOR MINING FOR
WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE.
YES MADAM PRESIDENT.
WANNA.
REQUEST FROM JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO MEET AND THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE A MEDIATE LEE.
AND THEN WE WILL RETURN TO THE
FLOOR SO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE SOONER YOU GET IN
THERE THE SOONER WE'LL BE BACK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS MEETING
OFF THE FLOOR IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO START
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SENATOR DORADO.
SHE WAS LISTENING.
SENATOR DORADO AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK PLEASE PROCEED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES SISTERS AND BROTHERS.
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LET THE NO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
HAVE THE GREAT HONOR THIS
MORNING.
OF INTRODUCING OUR ICON THE
LOTUS WORD.
SHE IS KNOWN TO MOST OF US.
IN THE WAY THAT SHE STARTED AS A
REGULAR [inaudible]
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER.
AND DECIDED TO DEVOTE HER LIFE.
TO THE CONDITIONS PARTICULARLY
OF FARMWORKERS OF POOR PEOPLE
BUT THEN GREW TO EMBRACE SO MANY
OTHER.
THE ISSUES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE TOO MANY TOO MANY
ACHIEVEMENTS AND SUCCESSES FOR
ME. TO NAME.
BUT AS WAS SAID ON THIS MORNING
IN PRAYER -- REFERENCE TO THE
LOTUS WAS MADE ABOUT HER
CONVICTION AND OUR COMMITMENT TO
NONVIOLENCE WELL.
ON THE WEST COAST OF THE COUNTRY.
NONVIOLENCE WAS SOMETHING THAT
WE LEARNED FROM THE LOTUS AND
FROM SAYS SIDE.
AND THE FARMER GIRL MOVEMENT AND
THEY WERE BEGINNING TO MAKE
THOSE CONNECTIONS WITH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN THE NON
VIOLENT MOVEMENT OF DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
AT EIGHTY NINE YEARS YOUNG
YESTERDAY WAS HER BIRTHDAY.
THE LAWYERS CONTINUES TO WORK
TIRELESSLY DEVELOPING LEADERS
AND ADVOCATING FOR THE POOR FOR
WOMEN'S ISSUES AND FOR CHILDREN.
AGAIN SHE WAS A CO FOUNDER OF
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS UNION.
LATER SHE BOB FOUNDED THAT THE
LOTUS WHERE THOU FOUNDATION SHE
TRAVELS ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY
ENGAGE IN AND SUPPORT IN
LEGISLATION -- IN CAMPAIGNS BUT
NO MATTER WHAT THE ISSUE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE WOMEN'S
ISSUES SHE ISN'T THERE.
NO MATTER WHERE SHE IS NEEDED HE
HAS A LIFETIME WORK OF
LEGISLATION.
LAST YEAR OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
ESTABLISHED APRIL TENTH AS THE
LOTUS WORK THAT DAY.
AND THE JUST AS A LITTLE
REMINDER WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
RECEPTION FOR HER -- LOCK LATINO
CAUCUS IN WOMEN'S CAUCUS AT TEN
O'CLOCK THIS MORNING.
I JUST WANT.
TO SAY FINALLY BEFORE ENDING IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE PRESIDENT
OBAMA BESTOWED UPON DELORES HURT
HIS MOST AND THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS AWARD IN THE NATION
FOR A CIVILIAN.
THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF
FREEDOM AGAIN THE HIGHEST
CIVILIAN CIVILIAN AWARD IN THIS
COUNTRY.
JOINING THE LAWRENCE TODAY IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY OR MANY OF HER FAMILY
MEMBERS AND STUDENTS.
WHO ARE BENEFITING FROM THE
LOTUS WHAT THE FOUNDATION YOUTH
AND FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY ON A PERSONAL NOTE?
AS I'VE GROWN IN THE MOVEMENT
ARE TRIED TO LEARN FROM THE
WOMAN THERE'S NOBODY THAT WAS
MORE STAUNCHLY AT MY SIDE WITH
ADVICE WITH IT WAS PERSONAL
WEATHER WAS TO SCOLD ME.
WHETHER IT WAS TO LIFT ME UP --
SHE WAS ALWAYS THERE AND HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THERE I AND HE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR RECRUITING MY
HUSBAND WHEN HE WAS EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD AND SAY -- I NEED YOU
TO GO FOR A COUPLE OF MONTHS TO
WORK ON THE BOYCOTT.
AND HE SAID OKAY BUT HE ENDED UP
BEING SENT TO CANADA FREEZING
WEATHER FROM DIE NEUE BUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND BECOMING AN EXTRAORDINARY
LABOR LEADER IN HIS LIFETIME SO
SISTERS AND BROTHERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING OF THE LOTUS
WORD BACK TO THIS LEGISLATURE.
WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR GALGIANI I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE A PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR
.
CENTER GALGIANI AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FAIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS UPON THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE
AGRICULTURAL.
ADVISORY COUNCIL HAS SELECTED
SECRETARY KAREN ROSS AS THEIR
AGRICULTURALIST OF THE YEAR.
THIS AWARD IS PRESENTED TO AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY.
THE CRITERIA TO BE CONSIDERED
FOR THIS PRESTIGIOUS AWARD IS
RIGOROUS.
CANDIDATES MUST HAVE
DEMONSTRATED STRONG LEADERSHIP
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
FINANCE GOVERNMENT PRODUCTION
EDUCATION LABOR RESEARCH
COMMUNICATIONS TRADE AND PUBLIC
SERVICE.
THROUGH HER MANY YEARS OF
DEDICATION TO THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY.
SECRETARY ROSS HAS SHOWN TO LEAD
THE CHARGE IN ALL OF THESE AREAS
AND IS HELD IN HIGH REGARD BY
ALL IN THE INDUSTRY.
SECRETARY ROSS HAS WORKED WITH
GOVERNMENT ACADEMIA AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP THE AG
INDUSTRY DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON OUR FARMERS AND
RANCHERS.
SHE HAS INITIATED PROGRAMS FOR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS TO ENGAGE
AND SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION
PRACTICES THROUGH WATER
CONSERVATION AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY JUST TO NAME A FEW.
SHE HAS SHOWN GREAT LEADERSHIP
AND TRYING TO CONNECT CONSUMERS
TO ERICA AGRICULTURAL BY
IMPROVING ACCESS TO HEALTHY AND
NUTRITIOUS CALIFORNIA GROWN
PRODUCTS.
SECRETARY ROSS KNOWS WHAT SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT MEMBERS SHE AND
HER HUSBAND VERY OWN EIGHT
HUNDRED ACRES OF LAND WHERE THEY
GROW KNOW TILL WE AND FEED
GRAINS INCORPORATING COVER CROPS
AND ROTATIONAL GRAZING. FOR BEEF
PRODUCTION SO MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO HONOR SECRETARY
ROSS ON THE FLOOR TODAY FOR HER
CONTINUED DEDICATION.
PASSION AND PARTNERSHIP AND
PRESERVING CALIFORNIA'S PLACE IN
THE GLOBAL GLOBAL MARKET OF
AGRICULTURE FOR FINDING WAYS FOR
THE INDUSTRY TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND FOR WORKING TOWARDS ENSURING
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA GROWN
PRODUCTS THANK YOU.
WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE CONGRADULATIONS
.
MEMBERS BEFORE I RECOGNIZE
SENATOR MITCHELL I'M JUST GOING
TO ASK EVERYONE TO BE RESPECTFUL
OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE SPEAKING.
AND IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION GO AHEAD AND JUST
TAKE IT OUTSIDE OF CHAMBERS
SENATOR MITCHELL AT THE PRO
TEM'S DESK.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES GOOD MORNING.
I'D LIKE TO RISE TODAY IN
RECOGNIZE DOCTOR JANET TALKS
WITH THE RESOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA.
WHO WAS CALLED HOME UNEXPECTEDLY
YESTERDAY?
BACK TO TALK TO THE PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST AND
IS CLOSE TO COMPLETING HER TURN
HER TERM.
AS CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA PLANNED PARENTHOOD
EDUCATION FUN.
DURING HER TERM DOCTOR TOSH LED
THE BOARD TO NUMEROUS INNOVATIVE
STATEWIDE COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS
INCLUDING HELPING TO SECURE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW FUNDS FOR FAMILY
PLANNING PROGRAMS.
AND ESTABLISHING PUBLIC HEALTH
PRIORITIES.
HER LEADERSHIP AND CONTRIBUTIONS
HAVE ATTRIBUTED TO CALIFORNIA
PLANNED PARENTHOOD BEING POLEIS
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS SERVED.
ACROSS THE STATE IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS EXPAND THE TYPES OF
SERVICES OFFERED DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE WAIT TIMES IN HIGH NEED
AREAS AND OPEN.
MUCH NEEDED NEW HEALTH CENTRS
BOTH PHYSICALLY AND VIRTUALLY.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE HELP ME
RECOGNIZING HER FOR HER EFFORTS
AND WISH YOU HEARD THE BASS I
SHE LOOKS TO CONTINUE HER WORK
IN THE CENTRAL COAST COMMUNITY.
DOCTOR TOUCH.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE [inaudible]
PLEASE NOTE [inaudible]
WOMEN
[inaudible]
I AM.
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR APRIL EIGHTH
THROUGH OF THE ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS ALSO WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEASURES REPORTED FROM POLICY
COMMITTEE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING.
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED AND RE REFER
TO COMMITTEE MEASURES REPORTED
DO PASS AS AMENDED WILL BE GIVEN
THEIR SECOND READING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURN TO SECOND
READING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
MISTER SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT WITH
A WOMEN'S SENATE BILL ONE WITH
THE MOMENT SIX FIFTY FIVE AT THE
MOMENT FORTY FOUR WITH THE
MOMENTS THAN BEFORE. NINETEEN
SEVEN FORTY THREE ONE EIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY THE
SECOND READING WILL BE DEEMED
READ WE'RE NOW MOVING TO THIRD
RESEND THIRD READING.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR MITCHELL
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
BUT I'M SORRY MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE BILL.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW RELATING TO THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN SENATOR
MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES --
MEMBERS THE NEXT FORTY EIGHT
MEASURES.
SENATE BILLS SEVENTY FOUR
THROUGH. 858-729-8100 TO ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN AND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THROUGH.
ONE TWENTY FOUR ARE BEING SENT
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR
PURPOSES OF BECOMING BUDGET
TRAILER BILL VEHICLES.
AS PART OF THIS PROCESS THE
ASSEMBLY WILL SEND ASSEMBLY
NUMBER BILLS TO OUR HOUSE.
TOGETHER THESE BILLS WILL
CONTAIN THE FINAL IMPLEMENTING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
STATE BUDGET.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WILL BE ADDED
TO THESE BILLS IS BEING VETTED
THROUGH OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS.
CURRENTLY.
THE MAJORITY OF THIS LANGUAGE
HAS BEEN POSTED FOR ANYONE TO
REVIEW ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES WEBSITE SINCE THE FIRST
OF FEBRUARY.
THROUGH TODAY THE SENATE WILL
HAVE HELD FIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND THIRTY ONE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS WITH
ADDITIONAL HEARING SCHEDULED.
THROUGH MID MAY.
WE ARE WELL UNDER WAY IN THE
CONSIDERATION CRAFTING OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET.
THERE IS MUCH WORK REMAINING TO
MAKE SURE A BALANCED AND WELL
CONSIDERED BUDGET IT DELIVER TO
THIS FLOOR BY JUNE FIFTEENTH.
THIS ACTION IS A PROCEDURAL STEP
TO ENSURE AN ON TIME DELIVERY OF
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET.
LET'S PROCEED TOWARD GETTING A
BUDGET COMPLETE IT.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
NIELSEN.
ABOUT A PRESIDENT IN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I URGE A NO
VOTE ON EVERYONE OF THESE BILLS
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE TAKE A
ROLL CALL AND THEN JUST
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE ON THE LAST
WE DO NOT NEED TO GET BOGGED
DOWN.
MY OBJECTION IS EVERY YEAR THE
PROLIFERATION.
OF BUDGET TRAILER BILLS.
IN FORMER TIMES.
THESE BILLS WHAT SPECIFICALLY
ARE NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BUDGET WOULD
RANGE FROM FIVE MAYBE.
TEN AND EVERY YEAR WE GET MORE
AND MORE THIS YEAR NOW.
FORTY EIGHT PLUS WHATEVER COMES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY ARE RUNNING
AROUND.
THE ISSUE IS NOW WE ARE DOING
MAJOR POLICY.
IN THE BUDGET.
EMBODIED IN TRAILER BILLS AND
THOSE HEARINGS ARE NOT THE ROLE
IT IS NOT AND LIBERTY PROCESS.
WE DEAL WITH A MAJOR ISSUE LAST
YEAR.
A SUBCOMMITTEE OF ONLY FOUR
MEMBERS.
AND THE SENATE WERE ALL THAT
HEARD THE BILL.
IT HAPPENS ALL TO REGULARLY IT
IS NOT JUST TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I URGE A NO VOTE
ON ALL OF THESE TRAILER BILLS.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING HEARING NONE SENATE
MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I'D LIKE TO VERY MUCH WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE WHO SERVES AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
WELL HAVING SERVED AS CHAIR OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR MOST OF MY
TENURE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
I'M CLEAR ABOUT THE HARD WORK
THE HOURS UPON HOURS THAT WE ALL
COMMIT. TO SITTING THROUGH THOSE
A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS
THE HOURS THAT STAFF KOREAN TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE FOUND THE
GENDERS AND GREAT BRIEFING
DOCUMENTS.
WILL ALL REMEMBER THAT WE'RE NOW
OPERATING UNDER THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RULE IN WHICH DOCUMENTS
MUST BE IN PRINT BEFORE WE ARE
ABLE TO VOTE ON THEM.
GIVEN THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE THE PROCESS THAT IS THE
FISSION AND COMPREHENSIVE AND
ONE THAT ALLOWS US TO HAVE
VEHICLES MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT WILL BE POPULATED
WITH ISSUES THAT ARE THAT IT IN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE PROCESS.
AGAIN THIS IS A PROCEDURAL ASK
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NO BILL.
HI WE'RE JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI CARRIER -- I CHIANG
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
BY DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI HI [inaudible]
JONES NO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY [inaudible]
BY WINNER BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
JACKSON WILK [inaudible]
NO.
HIGHS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO GET YOUR ATTENTION.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ A THIRD TIME.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY FIVE THROUGH.
EIGHTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN THROUGH.
NINETY EIGHT ONE HUNDRED THROUGH.
ONE NINETEEN AND ONE TWENTY ONE
THROUGH.
ONE TWENTY FOUR FILE ITEMS.
TWENTY EIGHT THREE SEVENTY FOUR
IF THERE IS NO OBJECTION THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL OF ICE TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS NINE WILL BE ADOPTED
TO SENATE BILL 752-858-7290
EIGHT ONE HUNDRED THREE ONE
NINETEEN AND ONE TWENTY ONE
THROUGH.
ONE TWENTY FOUR SEEING NO
OBJECTION THE BILLS ARE PASSED
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO A KID COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
BUDGET SUBS OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE SENATOR WHY KELSEY
START US OFF.
MANAGER GOOD MORNING SENATE --
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TWO WILL MEET FIVE
MINUTES AFTER THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS THANK YOU CENTER WHY
KELSEY CENTER DRAWS -- THE
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR WILL MET TEN
MINUTES AFTER OUR DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL.
YOU HAVE YOU THE SUB FIRST THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR PAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT -- THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE WILL MEET AND ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE FIVE MINUTES
AFTER CONCLUSION THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATE
ROTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATIONAL MEDIA. TEN MINUTES
AFTER THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
CONCLUDES IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU AS WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANT
ROLE IN WORK OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS AWARE THAT THE
MONDAY UPON OUR RETURN APRIL
TWENTY SECOND.
WE WILL HAVE A FULL SENATE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE MEETING AT NINE AM ON
MONDAY APRIL TWENTY SECOND.
I'M REPEATING IT TWICE FOR ALL
OF YOU PLACE YOUR STAFF STAY
HERE.
ALL I IT WILL BE TO TALK ABOUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
WE DECIDED GIVEN THE FACT THAT --
DMB PROPOSALS ARE COMING THROUGH
JAIL BC.
APRIL SPRING LETTERS TO THE
CURRENT BUDGET PROCESS THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW EVERYONE TO
HEAR ALL OF THE PROPOSALS ON THE
TABLE AROUND THE DMV.
MONDAY APRIL TWENTY SECOND AT
NINE AM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR IN A
JOURNEY MEMORY.
AND I AM GOING TO START WITH
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU OF MADAM PRESIDENT AND
AND COLLEAGUES -- TODAY I I RISE
TO TURN IN THE MEMORY OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMEN SERGEANTS STEVEN L. LE
COHN WHO WAS KILLED ON SATURDAY
APRIL.
SIX SERGEANT A CONE WAS WRITING
A TRAFFIC CITATION ON THE
SHOULDER OF THE SOUTHBOUND
INTERSTATE FIFTEEN AND LIKE
OLSEN ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
WHEN HE WAS HIT BY A SUSPECTED
DRUNK DRIVER?
WHO IS DRIVING UP THE FREEWAYS
RIGHT SHOULDER?
JUST FIFTY THREE YEARS OLD
SERGEANT A CONE WAS A TWENTY
SEVEN YEAR VETERAN OF THE C. H.
B. WHO HAD SERVED INVOLVED IN
PARK AND THEN AREAS BEFORE
COMING TO THE RIVERSIDE AREA.
SERGEANT MCCALL NEWS BEHIND A
LOVING WIFE AND TWO SMALL
DAUGHTERS.
HE LOVED HIS FAMILY HE LOVED HIS
JOB.
WHEN HE LEFT HOME FOR WORK THAT
SATURDAY MORNING HE HAD NO IDEA
A DRUNK DRIVER WOULD TAKE HIS
LIFE LATER THAT DAY?
SADLY SERGEANT MCKEOWN WAS THE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX CHP
OFFICER TO DIE IN THE LINE OF
DUTY.
HIS DEATH WAS A TRAGEDY FOR HIS
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY AND
CERTAINLY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I CAN ONLY HOPE THAT IS DEATH
SERVES AS A REMINDER TO
EVERYBODY TO NOT DRINK AND DRIVE
AND BE CAREFUL WHEN YOU'RE ON
THE ROADS ON BEHALF.
OF THE CITIZENS THE GREAT
CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EXTEND OUR SYMPATHIES
AND COLD CONDOLENCES. TO
SERGEANT LOOK OWNS FAMILY HIS
FRIENDS AND HIS MANY COLLEAGUES
MAY HE REST IN PEACE THANK YOU
VENTURE.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FOR ITS WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
SENATOR MORALE YES -- MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
BOY IN MY DISTRICT I RICE THE
JOURNEY IN A MEMORY OF A YOUNG.
MAN.
ALBERT MADRID IN EARLY MARCH --
ALBERT WAS RETURNING TO HIS HOME
IN HIGHLAND WHEN HE SAW ANOTHER
MOBILE HOME IN HIS PARK BURNING.
AND SO HE RAN IN AND WITH A
SWIFT ACTIONS HE DID SAY TWO
YOUNG GIRLS ONE WAS.
FOR THE OTHER -- WAS SEVEN YEARS
OLD BUT TRAGICALLY ALBERT I
DIDN'T GET OUT IN TIME MANY
PERISHED IN THAT FIRE.
AND SO HE GAVE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE AND HE'S BEEN
DESCRIBED BY HIS FRIENDS AND
LOVED ONES IS BEYOND BOLD AND
COURAGEOUS AND COURTEOUS AND
ALSO HAVE AN A A BIG HEARTHIS
FATHER CITIES ONLY SADLY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD -- BUT THE
BRAVEST MAN EVER NOW KNOWN SO
ALBERT'S DEATH HE'S LEFT BEHIND
US FAMILY AND HIS GIRLFRIEND AND
HIS COMMUNITY AND SO -- BUT HE
LIVES ON AS MEMORY FOR THE
THINGS THAT HE DID THE SAY THOSE
TWO YOUNG GIRLS.
AND SO MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND TAKE A MOMENT TO
HONOR.
THE MEMORY OF THIS FEARLESS A
YOUNG MAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR ROBB
PLEASE FREE HIS NAME FORWARD SO
WE CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM
[inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
IMMEDIATELY UPON THE GERMANS A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MADDIE
LOUNGE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THE
MEDI LOUNGE IMMEDIATELY UPON
GERMAN.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
LET ME THANK OUR COLLEAGUES --
FOR FRANKLY TO VERY LONG WEEKS
OF REALLY SERIOUS WORK HERE IN
OUR HOUSE.
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE EARNED OF A
WELL DESERVED BREAK I HOPE
YOU'RE ALL ABLE TO GO HOME AND
ENJOY TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY YOUR
FRIENDS AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
BUT ALSO THAT YOU GET A A LITTLE
BIT OF A RESPITE IN A LITTLE BIT
OF BREAK -- BECAUSE WHEN WE COME
BACK I KNOW THAT WE WILL BE BUSY
OBVIOUSLY ARE BUDGET CHAIR HAS
CALLED AT NINE AM MEETING ON HE
TWENTY SECOND.
SO THAT IS WHO WE ARE THAT IS
WHAT WE DO BUT I HOPE YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL BREAK.
AND WITH THAT AND OF COURSE --
RECOGNIZING -- THE BIRTHDAY OF
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES -- MR
STERN WE'D LIKE.
TO IS TOMORROW WHAT WE'RE NOT
HERE TOMORROW MR STERN SO.
WITH WITH RESPECT AND DECORUM I
WOULD ASK OUR COLLEAGUES NOT TO
ENGAGE THE PRO TEM IN DIALOGUE
POLICY SPEAKING -- AND AND I
STILL WISH THE CALLING A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
ALL NEED TO GO HOME.
SO -- WITH THAT MADAM PRESIDENT
I WOULD SAY THAT WE WILL
RECONVENE ON MONDAY APRIL TWENTY
SECOND AT TWO PM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL ALL LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
IS RECEIVED BY THE DESK WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY APRIL TWENTY
SECOND AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GREAT SPRING BREAK
MEMBERS